a week since the duke of edinburgh was
brought to the king edward the seventh
hospital
and sky news was given a rare update on
how he's doing
his youngest son prince edward the only
member of the family to talk at length
about his father
since he went in your father the duke of
edinburgh is in hospital
at the moment um do you mind me asking
how he is at the moment
um well as far as i'm aware well i did
speak to him the other day so he's
he's he's a lot better thank you very
much indeed and uh so
he's looking forward to getting out
which is which is the most positive
thing so
we keep our fingers crossed sense
frustration at being in hospital
just a bit i think that gets to all of
us so uh and then
that uh um so yeah you can you can only
watch the clock
so many times and and the walls are only
so interesting
in the summer the duke displayed that
same no-nonsense approach
looking remarkably sprightly at a rare
public engagement
just after marking his 99th birthday
but last wednesday the palace confirmed
that he had been taken to hospital
for observation and rest in a new
statement they gave
more detail about what he's being
treated for saying he's receiving
medical attention for an
infection he is comfortable and
responding to treatment but is not
expected to leave hospital
for several days with the duke due to
turn 100
in june it is understandable the royals
would be concerned
but words of support have been much
appreciated
well we all wish him well you're very
kind thank you very much steven thank
you
we've had some brilliant and lovely
messages from all sorts of people and
and we really appreciate that so
uh and and so to see i've been passing
them on so it's fantastic
thank you and it is media crews from
right around the world who still wait to
see prince philip
a reluctant patient who in the words of
his family
can't wait to get home rhiannon mills
sky news